all right mackenzie yes mackenzie
welcome back
you were one of the very first
interviews i did when i came down here
to this studio on skid row two years ago
two and a half years ago almost what's
going on since then a lot of time has
passed
oh since in the past two years um
let's see uh you're pregnant yes i'm
eight months pregnant
yes very exciting um
pregnant still on the street um
i lost my best friend like two weeks ago
um things have just gotten like really
crazy you know
like breeze who
yeah yeah interviewed before yeah
breathe
yeah that was from fentanyl no she was
pair she had a
abscess fused with her spinal cord and
they took part of her spinal cord out
and she was paralyzed from the waist
down
for about the past year and then she
just got um
infections all along her back and stuff
and they just like
took over and oh my god yeah it was not
yeah it was not an easy way to go but
she's happier now so so you're still
living in a tent
yeah i live in a tent down the street
still been doing that for a long time
yeah way longer than i thought like
i thought it had just been like two
years but apparently this is like the
twilight zone
and everything is like warp speed and
i've really been down here for like
almost six six years
yeah never thought i'd are you still
using
uh yeah you're using heroin right
yeah heroin and meth but i stopped the
meth but i
and i got on methadone but i still use
uh heroin
here and there yeah it's really hard to
be surrounded by dope
and you're surrounded by it every block
every every time yeah
yeah i walk down the street and they're
still hollering like trying to sell it
to me and i'm like
are you concerned for the baby yeah yeah
i feel really guilty
really good yeah and there's a chance
you could lose it too right
um yeah yeah it definitely has like um
really big like uh consequences like for
the baby like later in life and stuff
you know
that shows you how difficult it is to
stop these things
yeah like i give anything to be able to
like just stop
you know and
it's just not as thank you it's not as
easy as i thought it was gonna be you
know it's easy to like
say like you know like how
how can you use while you're pregnant
and how can you do that and you know
it's like
it's easy for someone to look in and
judge and and stuff like that but
when you have this addiction that you've
been fighting for like
10 12 years already and um
and then all of a sudden you get
pregnant you're supposed to stop using
like i wish this baby was enough to stop
using i wish
you know like more than anything but
like
it's it's just not you know and it kills
me
and this this is your first child or um
it's my second my first baby lives with
his dad in arizona
and the father of this child is uh he's
in a tent with me down here
yeah do you see any hope of getting
office
out of schizophrenia um
[Music]
i hope and pray that i will you know
like but the reality is like
i just don't know i just don't know
yeah it's got to be tremendously
difficult to find the strengths dude
yeah i moved like just down to
like like probably like six or seven
miles for the past year
like away from here and like you just
end up like finding like all these
reasons to come back
like like justifying it to yourself and
and
and making excuses and and oh well i
need to go back down to skid row for
this or this or this and it's
and like you then you get back here and
you're like what why
what is the draw of this place like why
do i feel like like
like why why how am i here again and
like
crazy yeah really is crazy it's like
it's like a the addicts are like moths
to flame
for real and they just keep coming here
it's their downfall no matter the cost
no matter you know the
the pain or the suffering or the hurt
or anything like that like you just stay
here and
then like you look back and you think on
it and you're like
why am i putting myself through this
like am i like punishing myself am i
like i just
it just shows i guess like how like
addiction is just not
you know not something that you can just
like
it's not always logical you know no not
at all
and then it brings up feelings of guilt
and shame and all that
yeah but just fuels the using and fuels
the you know
the cycle that you're just so stuck in
so the prostitution that you were doing
before have you stopped that
yeah i don't do that anymore now that
i've gotten pregnant like
that's just too much for me
and it's got to be hard especially as
far along as you are
yeah i can't i can't imagine because i i
know like
like it's already dangerous enough and
then like you add pregnancy and the fact
that i'm
i'm not able to defend myself as well
and and i'm way more vulnerable
that's just too high of a risk you know
like i like trust me i know
i'm doing way riskier stuff and stuff
like that and
but that's just like i i'm able to
to make do so far as well as i can
and support myself without like my the
baby daddy
um and and so i haven't had to do that
but with you and the father both living
in a tent and then you have a baby in a
month
that doesn't sound like a great
situation to be raising a child
no i'm i'm he's uh
he is so uh is kind of in denial about
about our situation um and i'm just like
trying to be as real
with him and realistic as i can be and
like
like we're they're not it's not like
they're gonna let it
first off the baby has to detox off the
methadone and the heroin
so he'll be in the nicu for 30 days or
or so
while they weed him wean him off um
and then like what are they gonna do
like be like oh i know you use drugs but
here's this baby and
good luck with it like no cps will get
involved and
you know and unless we really get our
[ __ ] together
like or crap together like
it they're just it's just not looking so
good
so if you end up not getting off skid
row and having the baby and
then is there anyone you can give it to
any family or like that i have no family
here
um my family is in um phoenix arizona
and i think my mom's in like minnesota
or something like that
um but they wouldn't help you out no
they don't um
i mean they're not they're cut they're
they're kind of racist um and the fact
that i'm with a black guy
is bothering there are most of them are
already not talking to me so
like me having like a half black baby is
like
oh i see then i'll be all for them so
no but so you're on your own yeah
yep definitely um his mom
uh is like super sweet and like
but she's in detroit michigan um
and she's having like trouble with like
i guess alzheimer's or parkinson's or
something
so that's not really an option either
so and the pregnancy wasn't planned
no no i hadn't gotten my period in like
eight years so i didn't think that i
could get pregnant but turns out you can
turns out you can so so using
heroin you lose you lose your menstrual
cycle
yeah is that right i i
i at least as far as i know i did and a
bunch of girls i don't know if it's
every girl but most girls but and then
most girls don't know that you don't
have
to have a cycle to to get pregnant like
you can still i'll be late and
everything like that i had no clue
no clue whatsoever
and after being down here six years what
what have you learned
about yourself or about life um
about myself
i learned that um
it being down here hardened me you know
it hurt my heart
it made me kind of angry and
and i used to when i first got down here
i was so naive and global
women get treated so badly here yeah and
just like get taken advantage of and
then it's like
the girls here like we don't like like
pull together and like help each other
out like we steal from each other and we
talk crap about each other and we try to
to sleep with each other's boyfriends
and and just just like
the total opposite of what we should be
doing you know like it's hard enough out
here for
for women like why are we making it
harder on each other like it's some sort
of competition
like you know like it's it's it's crazy
but i learned that i'm better than i'm
tougher than i
i thought i was like you know um
a lot tougher so yeah
all right mackenzie i wish you and the
baby the best of luck i hope you
figure out a way out of here because i
think that's going to be the answer for
anything positive
me too there's nothing left here
there hasn't been for a long time so
thank you all right thank you very much